while the faces of South Koreans forced
into hard labor during Japan's colonial
rule of the 1940s look on young lawyers
fight for those still living they say
the government's newest proposal to
compensate the victims is a complete
defeat
there are three surviving victims of
advanced age who are recipients of the
Supreme Court verdicts they have all
clearly opposed the government's plan
15 South Korean plaintiffs have waited
years to receive compensation approved
by a Supreme Court verdict in 2018 that
had also pushed relations with Japan to
new lows
The Landmark ruling directed Japan's
Mitsubishi heavy Industries and Nippon
steel to pay up or face a liquidation of
assets but Japan insists all World War
II reparations were finalized in a 1965
treaty with South Korea
trying to find a solution for the
decades-long Diplomatic Feud South
Korea's foreign minister bhak Jin has
announced a new deal that allows
compensation through a public Foundation
funded mostly by South Korean companies
it would keep however Japanese firms out
of legal responsibility
I expect the Japanese government will
respond with a comprehensive apology as
well as the voluntary participation from
Japanese companies to our government the
grand determination to forge a
breakthrough to improve Australian South
Korea Japan ties
the plan was swiftly endorsed by Tokyo
and Washington with U.S President Joe
Biden hailing it as a groundbreaking new
chapter for the Asian allies
who say they are tightening their
military Alliance to confront threats
from North Korea and China
but the plan faces legal challenges it
would require the endorsement of the
victims and their families to give up
their Supreme Court granted legal rights
for compensation
and for some that is a betrayal Eunice
Kim Al Jazeera Seoul